[Music]
thank you so much for joining me on 20
minute leaders
thank you for having me okay so it looks
like you're in your office but you're
not you're in quarantine in new york
right
my home office yeah wonderful okay so
we're gonna talk about these things that
are on your right and on your left
pretty soon
and because they're pretty fascinating
but before that uh
i want you to take me back to a time
where
you had some adversity that adversity
brought on
this idea for comigo which is a really
incredible startup that i can't wait to
hear more about in a second
sure so the idea for camingo came about
as a result of my uh experience with
panic attacks
i started having panic attacks when i
was a student at the technion
in israel and uh
sorry what did you study i studied
biomedical engineering
no okay yeah this is a long story by
itself
uh but but my panic is like i would just
say that my panic attacks were not
related at all to the technion although
it has like a very
uh frightening looking stigma
um no so it wasn't feel like the
technique just happened when i while i
was there
um and i was very afraid of the side
effects of
the anti-anxiety medications
what is a panic attack and we know most
people don't know it even what it is and
don't even know how to explain it so
what what is it paint us a picture yeah
so panic attacks
it's actually something that it's very
true many people are not aware to what
panic attacks are
i i'll i'll describe it from the person
uh
like the person who experiences uh the
view instead of the clinical
uh definition uh but it defined as a
moment of terror and what you actually
feel
is that uh people people are feeling
usually free
free free things either they are
um losing their sanity this is one
option the other option is that people
feel that they have a heart attack
or that they are going to die this is
what usually are the three most common
um like i would say thought that people
with panic attack
has uh have and you uh there is a lot of
physical symptoms as well like your
heart is racing
uh you don't feel your hands and legs
very well
uh sometimes there is a cold sweat um
these are i would say yeah i see these
are the most common
uh symptoms to it you kind of feel
fatigued in your muscles
and it actually uh the fight of light
response that is activated in our body
and it was evolved in order to protect
us
uh when we are when a lion is running
after us
um in the forest what is not
uh in our world it doesn't happen
anymore uh but this mechanism
uh um is activated once our
brain recognizes something that he
thinks can be
a real threat so i want to clarify
everybody experiences stress i
experience stress
you know especially in our in our
community where you know we we
are we aim high and we work hard
together what we to to achieve what we
want
and that comes with stress but panic
attacks are not stress
right when i experience high levels of
stress in my daily life
i can't say that i have a panic attack
no
no panic attack it's not it has it's a
very i would say very uh intense
uh um uh
stress level but it's not it does it's
it
it doesn't define as it's not divine as
a stress it's something
different uh stress
as some of the elements that we have in
panic attacks but it's not in the same
uh it's not in the same um i would say
uh uh strengths uh or the same feeling
so you don't have all this
uh all these physical symptoms you have
some physical symptoms related to stress
if you
if you are experiencing extreme stress
but not the ones of panic attacks
uh you don't get like resting hard in
those specific moments and it's it's
something that is very kind of
uh like panic attack is something
versus stress which is something more
can be something more crunchy
and then you have the option of going to
take medication for for
for panic attacks right that's what you
were about to say yeah so i was very
afraid of the
uh of the side effects of the medication
medication so i tried any other solution
that i was able to find whether
it's therapy and biofeedback and yoga
and supplements and i did relaxation
techniques three times a day 20 minutes
each time which was very hard while
studying at the technion
and and leading a team at albert but i
was willing to do all those changes in
order
to really um uh stop these panic attacks
and i think this is also one of the
differences between panic attack to
stress the pain is really really
um it's really really painful it's a
different level of pain
and um i found out that while all these
tools were somewhat
effective to decrease the frequency of
the attacks they didn't eliminate them
yeah
and i also noticed that i started to
avoid
places or situations that i thought may
trigger an attack so i stopped sleeping
because i had like one panic attack
while sleeping swimming my first panic
attack was
in the movies so i stopped going to the
movies um
so i i found out that from the outside
my life
looked the same but actually for me it
was a bit different
um and this was very frustrating for me
um back then it was mainly at night for
me that like fast forward
a few years forward at the beginning it
was six seven panic attacks a day
after that time a day yeah at the
beginning it was
very intense yeah it was very very
intense it happens in a lot of times
that the
first period is very you find some tools
um so after that of course it was it was
last and this was good but still as i
said the fear was there all the time the
fear from the next panic attack and i
know
uh today i know already to explain it in
the more like clinical words
um and we we know that the anxiety from
the anxiety is the real problem not the
anxiety itself in many many cases
um back then it was many at night for me
i used to wake up my husband to stop to
help me to stop panic attacks
wow one morning i woke up and i said how
come that i need to wake him up to help
me
to stop panic attacks if everything he
knows about anxiety i taught him so why
i can't do it myself
interesting and and as an engineer the
solution that i found for this problem
was to um to um
create a product that people can take
with them everywhere they go
and use it in order to calm the stuff
down immediately without being dependent
on medication or on other people
um so this is how it co it all started
of course that my
story is with panic attacks but we found
that that what
works for panic attacks works also very
well for anxiety for stress
for uh sleeping problems so if you ask
about the connection from
the body perspective once you are able
to activate
the relaxation um the relaxation
uh response uh it affects all those
symptoms it's just
different level of of intensity
okay so you're an engineer and you say
okay i'm i'm not just gonna
uh let this problem persist i'm gonna
find a solution so that also i don't
have to wake up my husband you develop
this
you engineer this device this product
that i'm assuming is a handheld device
right from with the picture i'm seeing
behind you
and you can use it to help to help
go through a panic attack and guide
yourself through it
yeah oh okay yeah very
uh yes so yeah so literally very handy
okay
yeah so yeah so what time ago does it it
provides
uh it's actually like the first
drug-free
device that provides immediate calm to
people who are
stressed or anxious or find it hard to
concentrate or find it hard to go to
sleep
um and it does so by regulating their
breathing pattern
and stimulating their senses in a way
that stops
symptoms in the moment giving them back
calm
control and confidence so this is
actually what it does
immediate account this is what is all
about but but what does it actually do
so how does it
provide this relaxation and this
calmness yeah so
this is a good question so kamigo
implements free
well-known stress relief methods or
anxiety relief methods
the first one is breathing regulation so
by using
light and vibration signal it guides the
users
to extend their excellation lengths
and uh there is a learning mechanism
that adapts the feedback to the user
performances in real time
because your breathing pattern is very
different than mine is very different
from a 17 years old swimmer or maybe you
are a 70 years old
i'm really really not i'm really proud
or a 70 years old smoker
so our breathing pattern is very
different and also my breathing pattern
today is not my breathing pattern
uh yesterday so um the device adapts
itself during the use all the time to
use the performances to make sure that
it
extend your acceleration length
according to your
current needs and by doing that it
activates the parasympathetic system in
our brain which is the system
uh that is responsible in relaxation um
so it when we are able to extend our
exhalation lengths we are able to
kind of um let the brain know that we
are out of a dangerous situation
and then the brain okay so simply the
act of exhaling longer
tells signals our brain that this is a
safe environment because we're allowing
ourselves
to exhale longer we don't have to to run
to continue running
in a very simplified way exactly
uh but yes it activates the
parasympathetic system which is we have
like two systems the sympathetic one
that it is responsible on stress and
focus and the
parasympathetic which is responsible in
relaxation and exactly as we said
we activate the fasting pathetic system
and our body
understands that we are out of of danger
so
yeah so this is this is one method and
the problem is that it's really hard
to do it uh by ourselves it's really
hard to extend our acceleration
uh length even if i'm like right now
we're speaking and i'll tell you please
extend your acceleration length so you
don't know how to do it like you don't
know what is currently your acceleration
length you don't know how to extend
so it and especially when you're
stressed or anxious it's even harder and
i i won't go to all the explanations but
there are a lot of explanation about why
um the second method is uh called uh
multi-sensory stimulation or grounding
in the psychiatric world
um and what like by the way that call me
go
is designed it's gently stimulates all
the senses except of the sense of taste
and by doing that it effectively touches
the users
from the state that all their senses are
overwhelmed by stress and anxiety
to a common focus state what does that
mean how does it
what does it actually do yeah so it it
gently stimulates your sentence and it
does it by just by
the fact that you have lights here that
you look at so you you activate your
visual
uh sense and uh the earring with the
noise of the vibration
the touch with the vibration and there
is also a soft touch to it
and we have also this part that i'll
talk about in a second
that has a relaxing scent um and this
method is very common
it's used a lot with people with anxiety
and trauma and their therapies start
guiding them
to look at the pictures when you are
anxious look at the look at the pictures
in the room or listen
to the noises or try to feel uh the
sense
but this is very hard again to do when
you are overwhelmed so the device is
uh is doing it just the by the way
design and it's the good thing about
technology that you can
simplify things uh very easily um
the third method is relaxing sand which
is this part
and we are using unique technique that
enables us
to embed aromatherapy oil into a solid
element so it's
it's totally solid so we get all the
benefits
of the sand uh the therapeutic and
emotional benefit
without the disadvantages of liquids
which is like how and how long does that
last for
because it can't get it's uh it's part
lasts for four to six weeks and you get
to with the device and you can purchase
another two for twelve dollars so it's
it's uh
i like the model yeah so it's very
affordable
sorry no i'm saying it's a great book
great business model i like it
great business model and i think also
it's um it's
very uh important from the user's
perspective because our sense of smell
activates us very fast um again i won't
go to all the explanations why but
you can tell remember the feeling when
you're crossing someone with a perfume
that you know that
it's immediately it kind of brings up
memories and feelings
definitely so uh it's the same
idea beyond that and uh using scents
that
proof to enhance relaxation and enables
calmigo to provide
calm very fast so the combination of the
free method
it actually would make it very very
efficient
i love it i'm so curious about your go
to market
how do you i mean i know i'm a software
guy i don't know hardware
this is fascinating for me how do you go
about selling this do you just publish
it on amazon do you go on kickstarter
do you advertise on tv how do you even
advertise for these things today
yeah so we decided not to go to
kickstarter for various reasons if it's
interesting i can
i can talk about specifically why uh
kickstarter is definitely a good go to
market strategy for some products uh for
us it was a question mark and we decided
not to
not to go to do that not to do that we
decided to go b2c
uh so to sell directly to consumers uh
our main
channel is online uh through our website
and
amazon as you as you mentioned and also
now through the fsa store which we are
very very
happy oh thank you including the eyes
uh congratulations yeah thank you thank
you very much we are very happy with
this
with this option um and um yeah so this
is
our main main channel mainly facebook
right now
as well we are also collaborating with
health
professionals right yeah so
um this is like we did like we plan to
do it in two steps first of all to do
b2c and then b2b b2c
but actually after we launched we
started receiving like i would say
twice a week at least uh requests from
health professionals to collaborate
really yeah so we're outreaching to them
yeah our strategy was to do first to do
studies we already did a few studies we
were waiting for them to be published
so to wait for the publication to do
more studies and only them to reach out
to health professionals but
actually we are we're getting uh
requests on
as i said like at least twice a week so
this is um
yeah we are very happy to see that
health professionals in the us
especially is really
eager to offer drug-free solutions to
their patients and
it's amazing to see that totally i mean
i would imagine any any therapist or any
you know any yoga instructor or or
anybody who works in this relaxation
place would come and say yeah these are
the set of solutions that you could and
commongo is one of them
and so that makes a hunt a perfect sense
to me and obviously revenue sharing
is an innate part of it but adi so so
talk to me about how do you
how do you go this at scale so is it
mainly your focus is okay now
sell sell sell are you already thinking
about extensions for new products
different partnerships as the ceo what
what are you
dealing with really at this point once
you're out in the market and it's
already selling on amazon
yeah so i think everything you said
so we are looking um to grow ourselves
of course
we are looking to create more we already
have
uh kind of strategic partnerships with
with the va for example
um as i mentioned we are doing studies
with the um
uh national health which is the biggest
medical center in new york so we are
working on
um expanding our strategic partnerships
from various reasons not just for growth
but also for ghosts
and we are definitely looking and
growing our b2c
channel in parallel we are already
thinking on the next generation as well
so this is another uh another aspect of
what we are doing yeah so it's as you
might as you
just described it's all in parallel uh
by the way health professionals most of
them are not interested in revenue
sharing
just uh just yeah and i think the
surprising fact was that we are getting
requests also from
psychiatrists so i think the ones you
mentioned are kind of
um it's kind of um straightforward that
they would like to offer things like
that but we see also collaboration from
more traditional like uh um
uh physicians or psychiatrists or
neuropsychiatrists which i think very
surprising and they are very interested
in just offering drug-free solutions and
without doing revenue sharing
we are offering that uh we are offering
all kind of programs with health
professionals and most of them
just want a discount for their patients
and just want to to take care so i think
it's really important
to mention it because i know some people
have like
they won't respect their own kind of um
uh i would say perspective or they were
like wrong impression about how else
professionals specifically in the us are
actually definitely definitely and is
this something that you found helpful
for yourself
i would assume yes and that you're a
user but but is that really the case do
you actually use it
so i don't have panic attacks anymore my
last plan was like more than four years
ago already oh wow
yeah so um so yeah so i think like
definitely for me uh it made a big
difference
um and uh yes and i'm using it today
mainly when i'm
working too much and i need to increase
my concentration
and or when i'm tired or something like
that so yeah so these are
the the times that i'm used to uh mainly
for
uh for those uh um for those cases
and carl and how many people are working
with you on this
so we are full uh four full-time
employees and we have a few that are
part-time
uh and we are working also with a lot of
freelancers so we
we try to keep uh the payrolls uh
quite low in order to survive as a
startup
uh but from this from the other end to
have the
um the specific uh i would say
walls in-house very very uh
very fast so for example the support we
are going to support emails from day one
although it's much cheaper to do it
outside because we think uh
this is one of the most important things
for a product in general but definitely
for a product like us so we are kind of
balancing
between payrolls subcontractors and
part-time
workers i love it okay last question
uh three words that best describe you
the hardest questions oh yeah this
question you should say
um okay so go with with whatever
uh comes to mind i think um
and probably it's very relevant to now
so i would say like probably an
entrepreneur
definitely of course um mother
and an engineer i think like this i love
it
i know i i think that's the best
combination entrepreneur mother engineer
it's like i'm a leader i'm a community
i'm a people's person i'm empathetic
but i'm also very technical i go down to
the details i think that's what it takes
thank you very much stay safe stay
healthy thank you for helping
potentially millions of people soon to
to be calmer and and
challenge their own panic and anxiety
attacks and
i look forward to seeing it to sing this
device on the streets
thank you thank you very much thank you
for having me and stay safe
of course take care
you